هذه المسائل همم
مساعده كل من هو محتاج اليه مساعده همم
بتطوير وتنميه
القرى وكذلك الحفاظ على المناخ وكذلك هذا
يعني بان
خطتنا في السياسه المتعلقه بشؤون الشباب
همم
تنفيذ العمليه العسكريه الخاصه همم وهذا
هؤلاء الشباب همم
الشجعان همم
يعتبرون مثالا يحتدى به لشباب الكثير من
شباب في بلادنا
المشاعر وهذه الخطوات الايجابيه همم
يتمكن خروج الجامعات والمراكز التعليميه
همم التدرب في المراكز التطوعه
والحصول على همم خبرات في المسؤوليه
الاجتماعيه والتضامن همم
اجتماعيه بما في ذلك همم مشروع همم روسيا
مشاريع الشباب
طب ناروتو
17 مليون شخص يشارك في هذه المشاريع ان
قلنا ان هناك 40 مليون من الشباب ف 18
مليون هو نصف عدد الشباب المشاركين في
المشاريع الاجتماعيه سواء في المدن
الكبيره او في همم
المحافظات الاخرى
دعم الشباب
الدوله ويجب ان يستغلها ويستفيد منها كل
الشباب للحصول على تعليم متعدد الجهات
وبعد ذلك العمل وكذلك همم
الشعور بدعم الدوله
الرئيسي همم روسي بلادي بوتين
جلسه مجلس الدوله الروسي